you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-2 game
let's try eform as a start and see what
we get
okay eying the white side of the
Sicilian yeah the last standard game I
played I was playing in the black end so
let's see what black throws at us here
many options choose one he six it is
okay I'm gonna go with 9c3 I think yeah
let's try Knight c3 I'm leaning towards
g6 g3 Bishop g2 as a a white setup let's
see what a black does 86 knight c6 t5 I
think d5 is better only after I played
g3 or I could just go straight in for an
open Sicilian decisions
hmmm I'm gonna go in with g3
take up a more closed type position if
d5 I think I'll go d3 what
don't want to do is make life so easy
for blacks queen bishop
or in other words d5 if I'm taking I'm
helping him out I don't want to do that
and I want to help my opponent so on d5
will go with d3 and basically with that
move I'm saying I want to hold on to my
strong point
efore although maybe that's not so
accurate cuz and d5 d3 pawn takes on I
think I might actually take with my
knight I give up my fourth rank Center
pond but I keep this dog and I'll open
for one my bishop place to g2 and also I
mean on d5 d3 pawn takes if I'm taking
with the pawn I'll have to go on Castle
door my name will have to retreat
scratch all of that we don't need to
consider that stuff anymore d5 is not on
board okay it should be something
everybody knows my bishop belongs on g2
so let's get that move in and move that
everyone already knows is gonna happen
least flexible pieces least flexible
moves first all right
probably council yep
at this point there's a castle there's a
deep pond move but Castle is the is the
move here maybe I still go with d4 I
could still turn I still I still could
go in that direction
for a moment there I forgot I was
playing a standard game was thinking I
should move a little bit faster but okay
let's consider here it's a important
moment to go with the d4 computer will
be suggesting d4 but certainly d3 is
playable
hmm I don't think I've played this in a
standard game before while recording at
least no maybe I'm off with that but
let's let's go with d3 setup
okay and now what about Bishop f4
preparing e5 I don't believe that this
is a this is something or this isn't a
position where white has any advantage
it's just one of those even ish
positions some playable setup so I'm
looking at Bishop f4 I'm looking at rook
to e1 hmm Bishop f4 there is e5 however
that gives up the d5 square and I could
play here look to take the night out and
then operate on the d5 square yeah I'm
gonna go with that I'm fine with seeing
e5
I might go for that which is a move that
would prevent me from playing e5 to kind
of break up their small pawn center
their d66 structure this is our first
time playing okay they are going with E
5 and I think I do want to go for this
yeah let's shoot for
I'm already eyeballing the d5 square
that's a that's a term
yes our sarin likes to use eyeballing
the T 5 square okay so this is a hole in
blacks position I may like may want to
start chipping away at the pieces that
control that square at the same time I
need to be mindful of this pin which can
be quite difficult to get out of I take
take and then just look to occupy the
square Bishop here and how do I ever get
out of the pin on any each three move
there's first Knight takes Bishop takes
then Bishop takes pawn no good so I'm
leaning towards h3 at this moment
I think I should go for that I don't
like capturing this night without first
being provoked it could take him out at
any moment
I think h3 is pretty useful so let's do
that so if we take stock of just a
couple of the central squares d4 and d5
d5 as a whole d4 is not can always play
c3 at some stage hmm that's a good move
I can't have a night here for the moment
sometimes that would be a fine move to
disrupt a bishop on e6 I don't want to
get rid of this guy how do I make that
happen
I'm leaning towards a knight move this
Knight
- probably D - I want my bishop to see I
think Knight d2 is purposeful and you
know what this is uh this is maybe a
journey he can have so many moves maybe
I have the time for that
I wonder some however about on Knight d2
might there be b5 stopping Knight c4
maybe that's alright
maybe it's okay that I can't make use of
c4
it's good to open up this bishops eyes
at the end of the day are there any
tactics actually hang on this is a nun
protected piece as soon as I move my
knight so Knight d2 is there Knight
takes here hmm 90 to 90 spawn I may be
working but ship takes Bishop there's no
Knight takes Knight no because I get to
recapture and I'm on this guy okay so I
could start my calculation there I
believe at least Queen d7 king h2 no
biggie
additionally I mean Knight d2 is
preparing possibly f4 okay so they are
going in with b5 and how will they be
reacting if I play f5 because I may want
to even go further and grab some
kingside space with have 5 g 5g for g5
stuff one thing I definitely can't do is
on b4 jump in here because of Knight
takes and on Bishop takes Bishop the
knight recaptures I'm down a minor piece
so this has my attention
hmm
the moment to take out that night so I
could be prepared to meet b4 with Knight
d5 I think it may be I don't know that I
want to play f5 just yet especially if
I'm going to be giving up soon my dark
square bishop if I want to move upon off
of a dark square I'm weakening these two
and his uh his eyes might start to light
up so maybe I could look at taking the
night ninety five and then look to kick
this night out mm-hmm I don't think that
that's a bad idea
is there any other moves to consider
here mm-hmm
gotta pull the trigger on some moves
soon yeah I feel bit uncomfortable with
playing f4 I I need to be able to play
here and I should probably just go
straight in for that yeah I don't think
it makes much sense to play out for now
and open up this bishops eyes bit odd to
see a delay here with the recapture is
black really considering taking with the
pawn I would be very surprised if that
happens maybe yeah in internet issue Wow
am I missing something here pretty much
have to recapture at the bishop
okay 95 and reply - I'm almost certain
is going to happen Bishop takes Bishop I
think so let's go right in centralize my
night operate on this week square in the
black position he could be taken out of
course and then we have a case of
opposite color bishops and in those
positions it's usually all about who can
better activate their Bishop I would
really like to see be form because that
gives up this square v4 isn't really
helping blacks so much I don't think at
least hmm a bit of a surprising move
okay c3 I think so yeah let's get c3 in
there I like that the rook isn't done
the a file anymore to be honest I like
this idea trying to get him to flinch
and he move or captured gives up c4 and
if black just holds tight with a6
preparing to maintain their b5 pawn
preparing to maintain control of c4
least I have the a file to work with
it's not being contested interesting
very interesting moment actually because
I could take with the night I guess
blacks IDs to meet pawn takes pawn
widths well the only square that's
available to the knight on b5 hmm if I
take the knight the bishop backs up
somewhere I could play d5 and have it
locked but I don't think that this is
really an environment that my knight is
so excited about I don't see really a
good spot for him if I'm going in for
this capture and then push I I want this
square for my knight
am I missing any other idea pawn takes
Knight they have to move the bishop
taking here is only helping to activate
their bishops oops let's get this
straight I want to take the bishop not
the night yeah I'm almost certain that
that's the way it take so ok their
knights going to go here I have a pawn
in blacks position I could play Knight
here right away but I think the bishop
will move and then the nidal move and
then f5 I could start with first a4 I
think I like that I'd really like to see
black give up the c4 square because what
would that imply it would imply that my
knight get c4 and it would exert
pressure on d6 which is a base point
within the black structure and taking it
one step further a keeping pressure here
places a certain restriction on the
black pieces the Queen does not like to
have the job of babysitting upon mm-hmm
I still have four that came up c4 pretty
quick
okay I think I should just jump right in
let's do it I don't see it better square
for my night also he conveniently
defends against any seventh-ranked
invasion I guess the main idea with this
is to make sure my rook does not get
activity over the a file so those that's
I guess the the thing that black has to
weigh in such a position is it better to
allow the white rook activity or the
white knight activity I think it was
better I think if I was playing on the
black hand I would have maintained the
b6 pawn to b5 pawn with a six but we'll
see one of these two pieces was going to
be activated after my a four moves so
this is probably a good reorganization
black is preparing an f5 move I could
even look further to c6 if I could
somehow get there that would be and
probably be a good idea I think I need
to be prepared to me AF Phi with f4 hmm
I have this square covered if I if I'm
ever playing f4 but g3 is vulnerable and
again in order for f5 to come about the
knight would first need to move I'm
looking at a queen move now
like Queen c2 I think I want to stay off
of d2
let me make a quick move not sure I kind
of know I kind of like my night on c4
well he is my best piece I don't know I
mean there could be some rare cases
where a knight can be on c6 and maybe be
not as effective as a knight on c4 in
this case it's true YZ cannot be
dislodged from that square but in some
rare cases had some experience where the
knight is just kind of you know once the
rook and the Queen ER out of harm's way
the knight can maybe be worked around I
wonder about just rook 81 preparing f4
for when the knight moves I'm gonna go
for that I think this is the side of the
board I need to play on
clean here would black really go in for
something like that preparing a push and
then a take and I think that that's
working expecting this 97 and then get
the F pawn rolling I'll have a well
it'll make some sense with my knight on
c4 it's important to it's important to
not just look at the pressure on d6 but
also e5 so they're really reinforcing
the e5 point I'm gonna make a pretty
non-committal move gets get something
fast in there I do I do have this in
mind I did think about this instead of
king h2 but I kind of want to stay clear
of this a pretty committal move moving a
upon near my king
it's an idea because getting the bishop
on this diagonal okay so the knight
backed off so it's probably going to be
the case they play off five I'm kind of
useful move can I get in there I don't
know I don't want to play f4 until I see
first f5 hmm but why am I in that frame
of mind I wonder
hmm-hmm I don't think I
good answer to that well let's still go
with something non-committal I think
it's fine one move later I'd like to see
this move before I play off four because
then the night at least can't go here
and make use of some weaknesses maybe
now I lean a bit more towards h4 and
Bishop here they're really reinforcing
e5 now yeah I like how I like how black
is playing this very patient f6 Knight
h6 Knight f7 I'm gonna go with this h4
Bishop h3 I may keep this structure
sitting and maybe I even have an idea of
playing Bishop h3 King G to Brooke h1 +
h5 if my bishop is on h3 he's no longer
protected but should I even play to
Bishop agent h3 what about Bishop f3
defending the pawn play playing f5 and
then this Knight can't move maybe f5 is
better and I'm never going to take on
this square though I don't want to take
on that square not going to do that I
don't know if this is the best Square
for the bishop but I'm going to try it
Bishop f3 King G - okay they're hitting
that pawn
give them up to be honest Knight a5 into
c6 yeah I think I need some activity on
the other side of the board it's my
opportunity to do that
I'm gonna try I'm giving up a pawn here
to relocate my knight on c6 and I'm kind
of hoping that he'll get some activity I
believe he will be quite disruptive
especially if I could land a Czech king
is here one day if the h-file somehow
opens up probably a bit far-fetched but
anyhow that's what's running through my
mind right away he's checking
opportunities because he will be getting
to c6
will he be offset with night d8 I could
still jump in as a capture on c6 gives
me a passed pawn and it extends the
scope of my bishop Queen takes a four I
think it's best to hop right into c6
before playing rook here can't work out
the exact details behind that yeah I
think that this is a good way to
relocate my knight I don't see this
being an inconvenience me keeping
pressure here I just feel like I need
some night improvement something to stir
up some trouble whether it's c4 c6 bo3
starting pressure on e5 okay so they're
ruling that one out but I believe I
could still run right in there no and
you know what's hopping
gonna give me an actor wow that's a very
surprising move I don't think that that
is right because next up is c4 Bishop
here and as I was pointing out with
these opposite colored bishops who could
excuse me
whoever can better improve their bishop
or whoever can put to use their Bishop
is probably going to be doing better so
now I could just go straight in for this
check and should I could probably do
without c4 and now probably let's get in
King G to h5 keep the c3 pawn sitting or
lock down on the Queen side completely I
actually think I like that idea yeah I
don't want to even allow any activity
along the B file I think I have the time
for these moves now maybe even go one
step further with b3 mm that gives up
this square so there's pawn push bishop
here stuff um I think I'm fine with
allowing b3 if they want to play b3 I
don't want to give up c3 there are some
cases I imagine where I could give up
the exchange and still be better because
of this monster here on d4 I think he's
so much yeah they're gonna go in for an
exchange sacrifice so now I'm leaning
towards getting my Queen to d5 because
they're gonna go in for that exchange
and they're on the a for pawn after that
as well you know what I should probably
forget about taking the rook who cares
about that let's do it I'm looking for
me
to open up the a file looking to make
use of the fact that I have control over
g8 takes sacrifices here you know I'm
not going to take that rook I don't
think looking to start some trouble they
can't take here just yet because I could
take and well at the very least they
cannot take back opening up the H files
too much Queen on d2 does have a purpose
stops g5 so the H file is going to open
up
and I'm pretty quick to get there
they're prepared to take with the rook
clearly know what about Queen g5 what
about my time uh yeah let's go here I
thought about this for a moment but that
allows h6 and g5 that would be not cool
I could do it next because on H six I
could take and then there's no context
there in a pin I think I want to play
Queen g5 next let's do it I'm not taking
that rook he's too he's too good
so how are they defending this now hey
each six pawn takes pawn if the Queen
comes over here now I'm taking the
Rucker suffer the moment these two
pieces are bottled up I'm trying to make
use of this one piece restricting too
and next up we have this in sacrifices
for when they try to close it up I think
this is a winning attack I'm not
mistaken I don't see how they defend g6
at stake threatening matin one this is
no defense cuz I could just smash
through you know I got this rook takes
pawn I take here it's a big turn around
I think I have this let me make certain
it's running mate in one shouldn't be
too much to calculate there's no checks
against my king rook takes here I have
this covered this is busted as far as I
could tell fine push takes Bishop takes
Queen takes with Czech Queen blocks I
take the Queen with the Queen yeah this
is busted I think there are a mistake I
liked how they played it up to the point
where they went into defensive mode I
think maybe they could have tried to
work around my knight on c6 capturing
here gave me too much gave up d5 and
yeah a big turning point big structural
shift so I just take here could even be
fancy
what's taking here on Bishop takes but
now just take here for mate I'm not even
certain this would be leading to me it's
a mating - coming up hmm I'll have a
look back I really liked how they did
things here with f6 Knight h6 Knight f7
maybe they just got a little too scared
of my knight on c6 I think there was
maybe a way they could have worked
around it capturing the knight on c6
gave me too much I was able to put to
use my bishop and see blacks gonna do
I'll just play this one out - mate I
guess Queen Esther block let's see even
go back in just in case I'm getting
known afraid no I'm not getting none
friend alright they resigned let's go
into the analysis
because I think
um I think black was better can I say
let me let me click on the computer
analysis and that'll come up shortly
yeah I think black was better once we
had this structural shift right around
here pretty sure these next several
modes it'll be leaning in blacks favor
you know I mean I know this I think
black how black Plata is fine this is a
bit a bit of a debatable move one of
these two as mentioned is going to get
active let's see what the computer
suggestions are I really liked how black
played it I don't know like up until
this point here again I'm a bit iffy on
whether or not be four or a six should
have been played but even right here
that's pointing out g6 very important
moment because Queen d7 you're signing
up for this whether or not it's good I'm
not sure but I know I have this as a
possibility at least whereas keep the
Queen here my knight can't can't do that
it's pointing out g5 hmm I didn't even
consider that and that's a bit bit of a
strange move it's pretty soon I when
we're getting to the age file I don't
know let's let's see what the computer
saying well it has it as even down for
quite some time yeah tight game f5 and
when I played Bishop f3 this is the
first moment where it really doesn't
like it actually at this point here
where it suggests g5
let's put this evaluation on what's the
great story behind g5 I mean my first
thought is just take them out night
takes and I guess I can't get away with
this stuff right my Kings getting lured
out
it's what my instinct tells me like real
quick to just do something like this but
yeah there's some concrete line given
enough time I'm trying to operate on the
H file but do I have the time is the big
question I don't think I do
and if I'm playing here well how exactly
do I get a rook here I guess I could try
for this first but there's very direct
stuff
for f3 queen may be sneaking in mmm okay
g5 yeah I don't know this is a very
interesting pawn break if we look at the
other pawn breaks I don't believe
they're helpful takes takes I don't know
what the great follow up is for the rook
it's a super night on c4 if we look at
instead of this capture a push here
that's dropping upon although I guess
there's some play here for black opening
up e5 for the minor pieces and on this
move it's weakening the light squares I
could already slither in there to e6 I
think the important point and this is
this is a moment where I think could
easily misunderstand this structure I
was pointing out where at this stage I
could play f5 and I think that this
might oh well that's another reason not
to play because of this pressure here I
can't I can't maintain upon here I'm
dropping h4 but let's just assume for
the moment that there isn't this capture
in fact let's go one step back this is
the reason why I didn't want to play f4
it's because I'm never threatening to
capture on e5 after f5 misen by the
computer well it was for a moment but I
don't want this to happen
I don't want to give black this square
on e5 I get okay I guess I could take it
away with E 5 but I didn't see hmm ok if
I could take it away with with d5 maybe
this is something but this this is what
I was thinking during the game I was
thinking well if I take here they're
gonna be able to recapture and keep a
piece on e5 but I could control it with
d4 and then even look at this square the
week square and blacks position this
hole on e6 okay I guess I could go in
for f4 still prefers black okay
interesting I stayed away from f4 and
then I guess they should have gone in
for g5 there they played Queen d7 I go
for this Knight reposition it's right
around equal now how that right yeah for
just a little bit and it doesn't like
the knight d8 idea so I'm jumping in
doesn't want to capture the night yeah
this is where there's a shift g5 was the
improvement here for black instead of
Queen d7 and now after the capture and
I'm getting to d5 it's just going to be
in my favor from here on out not a
winning advantage but a certain point
got to be quite difficult this is one of
those positions where you have the time
to you know this is this is what I want
to do I want to play in the Kings side
but I'm looking to invest some Tempe
first with moves like c4 to shut down
the Queen side make sure that there's
not going to be any activity there and
that will buy me some time to get the
moves in on the Kings side the King G
twos the rock H ones H fives those moves
to open up the H file so that's why I'm
going with c4
and then opening up the kingside things
really turned as soon as there was that
structural shift as soon as there was
that capture on c6 and I guess it's
already very important that black and
make sure the H file does not open up
because that combined with the bishop on
d5 is really too much
it's busted from here I should be going
straight in for Queen there huh I
thought I point out in the game I should
not go for this because of h6 oh wow
that's nice huh
I could still play pawn takes pawn here
I thought on h6 I back off and then
there's g5 and things are closed the H
file is closed at least but even in this
position I could take this is nice
giving up the Queen
and we're still gonna be winning the
house picking up the Queen and mate soon
I imagine oh that's interesting so Queen
g5 I could have played right away but
alright if I went in for just this
recapture if I was materialistic
grabbing here I don't really know how to
assess this position it's still tricky I
was a bit worried about dropping my a4
pawn I don't know how active my rooks
are really going to get I guess I still
get some activity on the H file but I
thought it better to maintain my bishop
on d5 and go in for some attack against
their king and not be too concerned
about being down upon in this position
four five six and five seven and they
still have a full rack of pawns not as
important as the activity of the bishops
yeah and this is just going straight in
for me hmm interesting game clearly we
could see very very tight for some time
up to move 2022 call it I really like
how black played it and just right
around here there could have been an
adjustment this felt awkward
I know during the game I was like Bishop
h3 King g2 or Bishop f3 it felt awkward
and this is maybe a way to take
advantage of this the g5 and a knight
immediately striking at this now well
it's a loose piece on f3 black starts
giving direction to me
okay well interesting game as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below
and as always I hope you got something
out of it that's all for now take care
bye
you